in Washington President Biden gives a
State of the Union Address tonight the
president plans to highlight the
accomplishments of the past two years
but in the latest CBS News poll 62
percent of people in this country say
that this country is divided more than
40 percent say the U.S is weak and only
11 percent believe America is prospering
Nancy Cortes is at the White House Nancy
it depends on where you're from some
Democrats say great job Republicans are
saying not so much should be very
interesting speech tonight
that's right Gail White House officials
tell us that the president plans to
spike strike an optimistic tone tonight
that he'll talk all about the areas
where he thinks he can work with the
Republicans who now control the House of
Representatives but as you pointed out
this new CBS News poll shows he's got
some work to do convincing the American
public that he's got the right plans for
the year ahead
just have a conversation with American
people tonight at the halfway point
through his first term President Biden
will describe what he sees as the
economic progress on his watch a
bipartisan infrastructure law
investments in computer chips and clean
energy and a surprisingly strong jobs
report last week that pushed the
unemployment rate to a 54-year low put
simply I would argue the Biden economic
plan is working and yet many Americans
are still skeptical a new CBS News poll
finds a majority of them currently
believe that President Biden's policies
are making inflation gas prices and the
overall economy worse thank you so much
you have a wonderful day you too Yael
krigman owns a bakery in Washington D.C
she says business has improved markedly
since the pandemic but it's still too
hard to find workers there are so many
barriers and so many challenges like
education and transportation and child
care and you know just so many
challenges that are preventing people
from re-entering the workforce the
president of the
last year's State of the Union Address
came just after Russia first invaded
Ukraine a moment for Unity in the house
chamber we'll continue to Aid Ukrainian
people as they defend their country and
help ease their suffering
tonight's speech comes on the heels of
the U.S military's shootdown of what the
administration says was a Chinese spy
balloon six in ten Americans say they
disapprove of Mr Biden's handling of
China
tonight the new house Speaker Kevin
McCarthy will be sitting right behind Mr
Biden he delivered a pre-buttal of sorts
on Monday President Biden wants Congress
to raise the debt limit yet again
without a single sensible change to how
government spends your hard-earned money
none
does that sound responsible to you
presidents often try to send a message
with the people who they invite to sit
and watch the speech with the first lady
in the house chamber well tonight among
those who have been invited are Paul
Pelosi the husband of the former speaker
who is still recovering from being
attacked in his home musical Superstar
Bono will also be there he's been
working to fight poverty and AIDS and
the parents of Tyree Nichols he's his
death sparked an outcry after he was
beaten by Memphis Police last month and
so their presence tonight should be a
very painful moment Gail
that's quite a line up there thank you
very much Nancy we all remember that
Tyree Nichols story CBS News will bring
you full coverage of President Biden's
State of the Union Address and the
Republican response to it begins at nine
o'clock Eastern Time right here on CBS